all right story time I have a friend
whenever he comes over we talk about the
usual things space-time artificial
intelligence consciousness what is it
you know the you should he come over and
here's like you've ever seen west rule
those like I've not seen West world
here's like get your [ __ ] ass on TV
and watch was well paraphrasing he's
pretty much a jest so I watched West
world and now I'm talking about well
[Music]
Westworld season one so Westeros is an
HBO series based off of a movie I
believe it was written and directed by
Michael Crichton I have my phone right
here I like the motivation looking up
point is it's a retelling of that story
and just imagine Red Dead Redemption was
an MMO but it's actually physically a
place it's some time in the future
there's this theme park that's set in
the Wild West most of the characters
there are hosts which are robots or
they're kind of like NPCs all the
characters in this theme park operate
within like hundreds of inter woven
stories and people pay a lot of money to
go to this place and essentially play
the game how they want look for gold
catch the bandits fight [ __ ] whatever
but some of the robot hosts the
characters in this story they start kind
of going off script maybe remembering
things at that point the show makes you
ask what is consciousness and are they
conscious and the show is really well
acted to Evan Rachel Wood plays -
generally speaking the main character
hard to say that because the show is
actually pretty evenly divided and
Harris's dude that goes there plays this
game alive he's ultimately the [ __ ]
but you look at him and you wonder where
you end and he would begin in a Red Dead
Redemption I went to that lawless ass
pit of a town and I just just waste
people because all the GTA games were
just like hey just shoot people because
I did that we all did that which makes
me think what would I do there
essentially you're not really killing
anyone it's a program but it's physical
and that's what makes it more real it's
one of the many questions this show
forces you to ask but the fact that this
is a production there is a whole
storyline going behind the scenes with
the game makers and the producers which
is great and so well-balanced so often
in a show like this or a movie like this
where there's this storyline
maybe this storyline over here that's
running everything you're either really
interested in that site or really
interested in that side you don't even
lis care about both sides this show I
was completely invested in what was
going on in West world and what was
going on behind the scenes in West world
Anthony Hopkins is the main one behind
the scenes who owns this park he's up to
something he don't know what he's up to
is he a good guy is he a villain the
last couple things I saw Anthony Hopkins
in including transformers - last night
you could tell he was completely phoning
it in in Westworld he does not phone it
and it just shows you the difference
between when an actor wants to be there
and when they're doing it for a paycheck
and the operatives still got it it's the
writing of this show that really hooked
me now just talking about the dialogue
we're talking about the execution of the
concept as a whole this show genuinely
makes you question what is consciousness
and how are we different than the robots
in here who start to remember things I
mean it's all programming but one could
argue it's all programming for us - and
I love that this show made me ask
questions so often we see movies or
shows about artificial intelligence or
maybe the rise of it and at the point of
my life I feel like I've seen a lot of
what Hollywood and movies TV shows that
have to offer so anytime a show can take
a concept that I may have seen in a
couple plays before maybe this meets
that ex machina meets Red Dead
Redemption as they probably call those
to execute it in a way that makes it
feel new as a win at no point does this
show give you the splice where it's like
before there was no intelligence and now
there is intelligence Rise of the Planet
of the Apes does that it has that splice
it's like at the moment the Apes get the
gas now they're smart you know that but
Westworld gradually builds that AI it's
not like anyone turns to the screen is
like all right folks
now they're self-aware they are
intelligent you never get that cue you
never really know that it rides that
really blurry line on what is
intelligence of what is programming and
as there's certainly a tangled web that
Westworld weaves all the storylines
really you feel fulfilled with them it
rewards you for your investment that's
important for a show or a movie to do so
many shows and movies not rewarding by
the end Westworld I was completely
satisfied and intrigued for season two a
couple times the show bounces around a
bit makes you feel a little confused but
although you may be confused at times
you're never lost and that's the
important thing
in the end Westworld was such a great
experience it was a show that hit me on
many of the checkmarks many of the
levels of reasoning I go to movies for
sometimes they go for entertainment
sometimes I go to get lost in a world
sometimes I go to ask the strong
questions of what is consciousness West
world hit me on multiple levels as to
what I consider good entertainment fact
it was really hard for me to think I'm
like what didn't I like about wess world
I can't really find it when there's a
show that I been just season of and I
want to immediately right then and there
go back and watch it from the beginning
again I can't really find a lot of flaws
on the show that makes you self reflect
on a personal level as well as a larger
level of humanity as a whole I think
you'll enjoy a route free on this one
actually the Star Trek The Next
Generation with Moriarty elementary my
dear data and ship-in-a-bottle if you
have not seen those two episodes of Star
Trek The Next Generation you absolutely
should all right so West world have you
seen it why did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you liked what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]